hey guys how's it going it sustained and
today we're gonna be talking about the
new 2018 MacBook Pro that just came out
and I'm so excited because I'm going to
be doing a little bit of a comparison
between the 2018 macbook which is over
here the iMac 18 core and the 2016
MacBook Pro which is over here but all
three computers behind me are completely
Specht out so the specs that I ended up
getting in 2018 is the 2.9 I 9 processor
32 gigs of ram and yes I did
opt for the 4 terabyte hard drive one of
the things that is a big misconception I
think with a lot of normal people a lot
of consumers who don't know any better
is hard drive speeds I know a lot of you
guys are super tech savvy so you
probably are already aware of this but
hard drive speeds make such a huge
difference when you're doing anything
copying files editing rendering those
videos that you're editing so I decided
to do a hard drive speed test I ran them
on all three of these computers normally
when I edit I'm editing off of a samsung
t5 Drive it is a solid-state drive it's
2 terabytes so because I travel a lot
this is what I basically edit almost all
of my content off of this is
significantly slower than the hard
drives that are inside of these Mac
books the 2016 MacBook Pro was only able
to go up to 2 terabytes 16 megabytes of
RAM and this is the i7 2.9 gigahertz
processor and this 18 core iMac pro I
did end up getting the 4 terabyte hard
drive and I also upgraded the RAM to 128
gigs which is quite excessive one of the
craziest things I think there were tons
of memes and stuff going around is the
price jump of the hard drive because if
you wanted to completely speck out this
2018 MacBook the 4 terabytes all is a
drive was like $3,400 that's a lot of
dollars that's an entirely new computer
the iMac pro 18 core 4 terabyte
solid-state drive the right speed was
two thousand nine hundred and eight
megabytes a second and the read speed
was two thousand five hundred and
thirty-one megabytes a second now let's
compare that to this drive which is the
same some t5 and this is about $800 the
right speed is 429 megabytes a second
and the read speed is 500 megabytes a
second I still edit pretty much
everything off of here but the past few
videos the Linus tour that I did in the
mkbhd video those were all shot on red
so I edited both of those directly on my
laptop and I could really tell the
difference because I was so used to
editing off this Drive that this is sort
of what my normal was and
till editing off of this right because
my previous MacBook only had two
terabytes so that was almost not even an
option to be able to edit multiple
videos on there two terabytes at the
right speed was 1491 and the read it was
1067 megabytes a second now that brings
us to the 2018 macbook pro two thousand
six hundred and fifty nine megabytes a
second versus the read speed of two
thousand six hundred and fifty megabytes
a second so really what this leads is
the hard drive in here is almost just as
good as the hard drive that is enzyme a
pro another thing that's new in the 2018
macbook pro is the true tone display so
much like your iphone or any other
phones or any other displays that tend
to change colors or shift as the day or
the light changes it is an option you
also can turn it off especially if
you're doing graphics or anything that
your color needs to be very true
but I've actually left it on because
I've been doing a lot of like email and
some scripts and things like that so you
can definitely tell a difference if
you're looking for it but what's cool is
you don't really notice it as the light
is changing like it's just something
that is it's just magically happening
before your eyes I don't really know how
to explain it I feel like if so much I
want to cover in this video but it's
super overwhelming to try to gather all
of my thoughts because I also want to
talk about the e GPU now I did a render
test just to see if it would make a
difference in Final Cut Pro and it
didn't make one at all where the a GPU
would come in handy and if this is
something that you're doing this will
also work very well with one of the old
2016 MacBook Pros the e GPU will work
great if you're doing 360 content if you
have a VR headset connected to the e GPU
it will use the graphics card in the e
GPU as opposed to your MacBook and you
can still have the external Thunderbolt
monitor connected as well so for a lot
of people who are just normal tech
consumers and they have no idea what an
a GPU is it is an external graphics
processing unit so what's cool is Apple
has basically created a plug-and-play
solution for an e GPU previously it's
not really that crazy complex but it
definitely wasn't as easy as a
plug-and-play solution and since it's a
GPU isn't upgradable what you have is
what you get but this thing is kind of
crazy because you basically plug it in
and it works like there's nothing you
don't have to do
anything else so if you do use the eg PU
and you don't use an external monitor
there will only be a few apps that
really will be able to take advantage of
it
one of those is DaVinci Resolve I might
have to ask some favors from some
friends who I know are very proficient
in DaVinci they can do a demo for me so
that I can actually give you guys a very
accurate depiction of what that actual
process is so let me know if that's
something that you guys would be
interested in I also would like to find
some friends who edit in Premiere so
that I can give you a full demo of that
oh I'm pretty positive there's a bunch
of people already on YouTube that have
done that already
whereas I'm over here final cut for life
I am a ride-or-die FCP 10 baby not to
sidetrack too much I actually started
editing in Premiere maybe like 15 years
ago and then I learned After Effects and
then after that I went and edited avid
for years and then I was like this sucks
why are we using avid to do some very
simple tasks I'm teaching myself final
cut and then I learned Final Cut and
then it just all was I guess it was
uphill and then it took a slight
downhill when Final Cut 10 was
completely redesigned and then I stuck
with it and then slowly slowly slowly we
were on the incline and now I am
absolutely in love and I think a lot of
the people who did switch over to
Premiere may be back and potentially
eyeing up Final Cut I don't know correct
me if I'm wrong
we now have way more advanced color
grading options we can edit 360 video
it's been my platform of choice I have
edited thousands and thousands of videos
on it what else was I gonna do oh you
may notice that we've got three xbox
controllers here I play fortnight on
xbox and uh Nintendo switch I wanted to
test out for a night on all three of
these max which crazy I actually have
not played for it on a Mac yet
surprising I know and then when I was
travelling at my sister and I would
actually travel with a PC and I would
play a fortnight specifically on the PC
while I was editing on my Mac so it got
a little unnecessary so I am excited to
try out fortnight I did just order one
of the five klg monitors I wanted to
find somebody that had it but none of my
friends had it so I was like shoot I
need this to test out this eg view
properly these are my three favorite
Xbox controllers this is my custom one
that I got
may come a little gamertag on it this is
my minecraft pic controller then last
but not least this is one of the newer
ones that they just came out with I love
this teal color it matches my iPhone
I've gone on so many changes in this
video I'm so sorry so the first test
that I really want to do is a render
test because most of my time is spent in
final cut and exporting and rendering
and compressor so I'm gonna export it in
the 4k system share settings and we're
off to the races I also have one of the
FLIR ones I've had this for so long and
I was like I think today is the day that
we need to bring this out this is a
reusable straw just in case cuz I got to
cover all the bases because you guys are
very perceptive and I'm sure I'll be
jumped for every absolute thing that you
possibly can think about so I do have
open the Intel power gadget so I'll be
able to get all of the data whether it's
being throttled the temperature by CPU
pretty much everything so we'll be able
to see this right here right now I'm a
little overwhelmed see the hottest part
of this MacBook is about 110 to 105
the sun's about 104 and this MacBook
over here is about well that's about one
hundred and eleven hundred and twelve
okay so now it's like 121 118 119 so
it's interesting because my CPU usage is
only about 27% I'm here it's like 5% and
over here it's like 38 and it definitely
does seem to be throttling a little bit
because it is not using its entire
capacity but it's also not entirely
using the full CPU usage the fans are so
much louder on this guy like
significantly louder so it is definitely
being throttled but I don't understand
why this one is so much quieter than
this one over here so are there
different fans it's been 7 minutes 47
seconds
we currently are here's our iMac Pro
it's really insane the fact that it's
only using like oh my god like three to
nine percent of the processor we've got
it's using about 32% this one is staying
at a pretty consistent 76 Celsius 72
Celsius 87 degrees Celsius it is
interesting because the fans over here
are so incredibly loud and the fans over
here are so much softer one of the other
things that is quieter about this new
MacBook Pro is the keyboard there's like
a slight silicon little layer that they
put under it which I think was probably
to avoid the problems that they're
having the previous version I never had
any really serious issues with my
keyboard but a lot of people were having
dust that was getting trapped underneath
of it so it was causing their keyboards
to not work properly
I did have a little bit of trouble with
my spacebar and the tab key and my
solution for that I just kept going like
this and it magically fixed itself I
don't know if that's a good thing but
guess what it worked let's test out the
keyboard to see if it sounds any
different as you can see this is where
the audio is coming from so I'm just
gonna place it right here you can
definitely tell there's a difference
it's not that substantial this is
interesting
am I going crazy in this specific test
are you gonna tell me that this $15,000
computer rendered this video slower than
the $7000 computer because I'm pretty
sure that's what happened
showing compressor exporting for K 2018
exported at 13 minutes 3 seconds the I'm
at Pro at 15 minutes and 15 seconds this
guy at 15 minutes 46 seconds
[Music]
hey this is future Justine I actually
completely finished editing this video
but a lot of you guys on Twitter who
needed me to put my macbook in the
refrigerator and see what happens so
there's been a lot of memes going around
about the thermal throttling on the i9 I
don't have an i7 to test but I also feel
like when I was exporting this video on
my 2016 MacBook Pro it was also
throttling so it feels like this is
something that they may have been doing
for a long time and just now I think
people are figuring it out I'm not sure
I've actually never tested this before
so I have no prior data except what is
performing right now to not be in my
fridge oh these are rotten these have
been here for months I don't recommend
trying this because it's really stupid I
know people have done way stupider
things on the internet so what I'm doing
I look like a genius these are also both
plugged in so that the variables are
pretty much the same
let's hit export and see what happens
shall we so they're both going now okay
I'm gonna be able to kind of see in
there so we are about three minutes in
26 27 percent of the processor about 88
degrees Celsius so here's the 2016 about
86 87 degrees it seems to be about the
same the frequency up here is definitely
spiking a lot more
down here
we're about six minutes in our
temperatures are ranging from about 108
here's the 2016 MacBook that's what I'm
saying about the same as well all know
the fridge is telling me to shut it we
have a problem
so here's 20 18 once more at about 9
minute 38 minutes 2016 and about eight
minutes as well I close this back up one
last time and let it finish I think I'm
getting worse performance out of my
fridge test all right looks like our
first MacBook is on and it is the 2018
MacBook let's bring out our contender
this is absolutely stupid and I hate
myself for everything that I just did
right now at least I was able to clean
out my refrigerator so that's one good
thing that we achieved today so my
previous export was 13 minutes in 3
seconds and this export was 13 minutes 6
seconds
I actually got worst performance by
putting my computer in the refrigerator
go figure
let's take out our other contender are
you done yeah this is not sponsored by
Mountain Dew or eggs or cheese or tomato
soup or Apple for that matter so my
previous export was 15 minutes and 46
seconds and this one was 15 minutes and
39 seconds so fridge export helped the
2016 MacBook Pro let's give you a round
of applause this is the first time I
played fortnight on a Mac I don't even
know how to feel right now
would you like to automatically apply
the best settings for your system yes
[Music]
like this is doing something weird I
don't know if it's the controller or I'm
used to having a touchscreen with my
purpose so this controller was
definitely messing up I've used it
before for games why are you doing this
to me now let me go get a mouse well oh
no whoever am I gonna put this
I need a dongle I just want to play the
game lets me play the game okay this was
taking a while to load so I went
downstairs to get a snack
apparently we're dropping in baby
it looks pretty smooth so it looks like
it's running on 60 frames windowed
fullscreen view distance far
hihihihihi pardon my snap there's 29
people left so at this point all I got
to do is hide out I don't even have to
build anything wait I don't even have a
weapon yet oh god I gotta go loot I'm
sitting you're trying to make a video
we're not saying it is in my game I knew
at least you know weapons I'll be able
to defend myself I think one of the
things that would help in this scenario
is having an external monitor and having
the GPU connected so in this scenario I
do want to test that out because right
now and this is this is not this is not
the best experience but let me go back
inside here and let's change some
settings to medium medium medium medium
medium medium I do still want to be
playing in 60 frames a second so let's
see if that helps oh yeah that helped
immensely there's 16 people left so
obviously I'm a freaking champion but
all I had are shotguns these are trash
what am I gonna be able to do with this
nothing yeah keke 14 people left the
storm is a shrinkin they should probably
try to find something that's a little
bit better than what I have got I would
like to be honest with you guys I really
never play with a mouse and keyboard I
think everybody probably has all of the
good weapons over here so it's it's like
defeating the purpose even Oh what's
over here oh just some ammo okay running
around like a fool with three shotguns
and yeah like what is that gonna do
gonna do absolutely no ho-ho Oh mommy
found herself a mini
gun do you wanna oh do I want I want
that I hear somebody eight people left
guys I'm super nervous I'll take that
hey Siri place look not wait and bleed I
forgot that these MacBooks have hey Siri
integrated now now playing wait I tweet
by Slipknot oh my god I gotta get out of
here
[Music]
I feel like this is my theme song when I
play for tonight because I literally
just wait no stop playing both ania page
that's what I get for trying to remember
Slipknot lyrics from back when I was in
high school I'm also upset that my
controller didn't work I'm gonna look
into that as well but for the sake of
this video and my rage that I have do
you want to test it out on the iMac bro
all right so we're dropping in this
already feels a little bit smoother than
the 2018 MacBook Pro did the question is
will right click work oh my goodness
let's get it will I be able to snipe
this dude is the question oh god I'm
soos I'm just scared you're gonna kill
me and I'm gonna be really sad about it
was hoping oh my god I gotta get I gotta
I gotta switch mice No
yeah cuz I couldn't hold the right click
in and then also shoot at the same time
you you're making me so mad surprise
this lg monitor actually showed up
overnight
it wasn't even due to ship for another
few days so this is super exciting
because I really wanted to test out for
a night on the eg PU and external
monitor so to show you guys how easy
this eg PU is I seriously do nothing I
plug it in you can see it but there's
like a little light that turns on the
bottom and it's activated I'm just like
click
and three two it's already connected the
monitor is actually a lot nicer than I
thought I've only seen it in the stores
and I've ever really seen it up close
and personal another thing this new
Thunderbolt cable is so freakin small
like do you can you please give us a
little more slack at least this is a
little bit better one of the great
things about the GPU is you can also use
it to charge your MacBook and it is one
of the first a GPUs that will allow you
to use a thunderbolt display so let's
test and see if my Mac will charge if I
unplug this it's still charging and this
also gives you four USB 3 ports plus an
HDMI out which means I don't need a
dongle for my mouse okay so already it
definitely feels a lot different than
just playing on the MacBook which I
would hope so because I am playing with
an entirely separate graphics card so
this is way smaller
look at that I can't believe it took me
this long to get one of these LG
monitors to try out this thing is really
really beautiful I also would like to
reiterate that I mostly played this on
xbox and when I did play on PC I also
use your controller which I know that's
that's like I've probably committed so
many sins in some of your eyes but I'm
not gonna apologize because really I'm
me you're you you do what you want and
I'm not gonna say anything about it
see we shouldn't say anything about my
choices let's break up stop all of your
goods printer yes you're dead I actually
used to play a lot more PC gaming gosh
that's really what got me into playing
first-person shooters like Unreal
Tournament and quake 3 I never I never
really got into csgo but I guess more
recently I played overwatch on the PC a
play Diablo 3 on pc but i really I mean
I'm just I prefer player and console
mostly because that's where my friends
play and I think that is kind of the
whole point of playing games is the
social aspect I mean it is fun to play
alone if you're playing like a
significant oh god there's something
over there
and it's definitely not ready for
confrontation was I saying oh I don't
know the social aspect of games because
I used to go to LAN parties
it it was a social experience but the
internet used to be so bad back in the
day that that was what you had to do oh
just give it away my freakin location
price no well this is running
I mean it's what's really really good
drink it up
oh no somebody's already been here oh
boy I'm scared I'm scared I'm not ready
no I'll tell you why this looks really
really good I'm surprised okay thank you
so much for watching this video I really
did enjoy testing this out there's so
many more things that I do want to test
out so I'm sure I will do a follow-up
video in typical iJustine fashion of one
week with macbook two weeks with math
book three weeks four days with MacBook
let me know if there's any other things
that you'd like to see me test with this
I know a bunch of my other tech friends
are probably doing very very
comprehensive in-depth reviews so be
sure to go check them out I will put as
I see them I would put their links in
the description so I will say that this
lg monitor is so beautiful and I can't
believe it's taken me this long to get
one it really does look absolutely
insane so all that being said I don't
even know what you guys got out of this
video if you got anything if you're
entertained if you love me more now you
hate me even more I'm not really sure
but if you want to subscribe feel free
to do so I'll have a bunch more videos I
have some fun things planned for you
guys and I look forward to posting those
and editing them so I would take this
monitor upstairs and connected to my
iMac pros having this much more screen
real estate to edit is going to be
incredible
[Applause]
[Music]